yeah I heard the story about Pete and
his brother and I don't know which one
did it but his father Pete Fairley's
brought father was a doctor doctor yeah
and so they're sitting down and they're
about to watch the football game on a
Sunday morning and Pete is like
hawk-eyed man I had such a night last
night and my ass is killing me this
father goes what and he goes now my ass
my ass is I don't know I just I went
crazy last night and he goes what do you
mean your ass is killing you guys I
don't know my [ __ ] is killing me I
don't know what the hell to do about it
and his father who's a doctor is like
well what your ass the muscles are what
he goes now the inside the ass my
[ __ ]
his father goes god damn it - well well
show me what the woods show me your ass
what are you talking about so peep or
what his brother bend over this probably
goes tough what the hell you know he's
he's dr. Boz a doctor he's like you know
you gotta whiz sons and he looks at and
and Peter's stuck a condom in his ass
yeah oh god damn it god damn it
they scream my god it's not funny what
are you doing sorry was there something
in there that's the kind of family he
grew up him he's that the funniest
[ __ ] thing you've ever heard that's
amazing yeah I have heard that story
yeah Pete's Pete's good for a laugh
let's put it that way yeah he's good you
know and he's he doesn't really like it
in the same vein that he'll call
somebody to talk to them because he's a
sweetheart
he'll also just hit you up to [ __ ] with
you and well I did it I get a charity
with you has never done a charity dead I
never did and he was in the audience and
I and and and Larry Kramer was there
what's his name Larry Kramer that's what
Larry and Larry Kramer runs a Seinfeld
Larry Larry David Eric idea and so they
did the auction one thinks the auction
off was a golf lesson and I was like you
get to play with Larry David and stuff
and and and it was we were raising money
for these sick children that were gonna
die it was very very kind of moving
actually and Jennifer Garner was there
anything and I'm emceeing the whole
thing and trying to sell off all this
stuff and Pete Farrelly just comes up on
stage when nobody was buying [ __ ] and
just takes Mike and goes whole lot
enough of this [ __ ] we got to raise
money got to do it now these kids let's
go Larry David is old he's not gonna be
around for long he's probably gonna die
in about three years so somebody better
[ __ ] buy up golf with Larry David
right now and that's how he starting
it's just an amazing guy yeah he really
is he's all fees all [ __ ] heart
yep there they are when I got stage I
was like let me let us be in your movie
be in our movie we love you so much
right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]